fixer-upper star chip gains addresses  divorce rumors I love you  [Music]  ship games wants to make it clear that  he and his wife Joanna are not calling  it quits I think that you make this a  funny place the HGTV stars have been the  subject of recent split rumors and chip  took to social media to set the record  straight  tweeting in response to a fan who said  they're sick of seeing the stories quote  won't ever happen  adding the hashtag love of my life the  couple have been married since 2003 and  share four children together and are in  season four of their mega hit home  improvement show I knew when I married  the guy this was gonna be an adventurous  life and it has not been boring yet  [Music]